this video is sponsored by raycon
earbuds
if you've been watching the videos here
on my channel for a while you've
probably picked up on a peculiar trim
that comes up every now and then
uh no not that trend a different one
i'm talking about my tendency to omit
majora's mask lore from my videos
like for my recent iron knuckle video
for instance towards the end
the fact that there is an iron knuckle
enemy in the alternate land of termina
from majora's mask is completely and
verbally dismissed
by me because i didn't want to have to
talk about whether or not termina is
real and connected to hyrule
and to be honest it is a pretty messy
subject since most if not all of what
happens in majora's mask seems to either
be reset by the end of the game or
simply has no effect on the rest of the
world and the timeline to come
unless you count this majora's mask mask
in breath of the wild
but i don't and neither should you the
point is it's pretty easy to say that
termina just doesn't exist because of
various reasons but that's not to say
there aren't perfectly valid reasons for
termina's actual existence either so in
this video
i've decided to create a sort of duality
theory that's actually going to be two
smaller theories that are opposite to
each other
i'm going to first prove to you that
termina does exist with logical
reasoning
and then disprove its existence with
similar
logical reasoning and here's the kicker
you know how i just mentioned that i
always tend to dismiss the inclusion of
terminal lore in my videos
well depending on which theory from this
video you guys believe
more the results will determine whether
or not i
talk about terminian counterparts in all
future theories from this point onward
so be sure to let me know in the
comments below which theory you're more
on board with oh
and by the way if you're new here or if
you've been here for a while
be sure to make sure you're subscribed
to stick around for said theories to
come and
drop a like if you enjoy this video
anywho we're going to begin with the
first subject
why termina is absolutely 100 percent
real but first a quick message from our
benevolent sponsors
hey you what's your name
are you tired of living with old
technology and dealing with wires on
your mediocre earbuds
well allow me to introduce you to the
new raycon
everyday e25 earbuds nothing says
modernize your life like they're
completely wire free design
and new bass boosting audio quality that
sounds every bit as good as other top
brands out there even though the
everyday
e25 earbuds start at just half the price
connect them to any device with seamless
bluetooth pairing and listen for up to
six hours at a time with their awesome
battery life
their cute little charging case comes
with four complete charges before having
to plug it in again
talk about convenient so whether you're
working from home
working out or just catching the latest
shows click the link in the description
below or go to www.byraycon.com
mmb for a whopping 15 off your order
golly gee wins and be sure to choose
your favorite color when you're checking
out
oh cut it out you silly goose you know
what color is
and now back to the video
termina has to be real right i mean in
the first place link isn't the only
individual who enters the mysterious
alternate land of termina through the
hole in the tree
his horse epona also appears to have
entered termina as well as the skull kid
and happy mask salesmen who both have
memories and knowledge of link's heroic
deeds from his past
future self however these individuals
all exist
in the memories of link himself as well
so the existence of these characters in
termina could be easily dismissed if the
argument is made that termina is a
construct of link's own mind
so we need to look elsewhere for proof
the biggest piece of evidence that most
fans and theorists tend to point to for
the existence of termina is at the end
of the game when two
very notable things happen the first of
which is of course
link returning to the lost woods where
he began his journey at the beginning of
the game
but this time he's brought with him the
gear that he obtained from his adventure
in
termina the mirror shield and sword that
you ended the game with can both be seen
on his back when he's riding epona into
the
sunset this would of course imply that
everything that just happened in the
game
actually happened outside of ling's own
mind the second and also
very proving piece of evidence would be
the drawing shown on the tree stump that
was obviously drawn by the skull kid not
link it depicts
four elements link the skull kid without
the mask thankfully
the fairies and the four giants the
reason why we know this was obviously
not drawn by link is that every element
of this image is centered around the
skull kid not around link
all characters present are considered
the skull kid's friends
like both of the fairy siblings or the
four giants in the background link has
little to no affiliation with them
besides politely asking for them to stop
the moon from face smashing the earth
and since
this was drawn by the skull kid in the
lost woods
outside of termina that would mean that
not only did the skull kid also make it
out of termina but the events of
majora's mask
were real to him as well this is
definitely pretty solid evidence for
termina's existence but one
final rather large question remains just
how was termina created
exactly we know how hyrule was created
which is by the will and power of the
golden goddesses
you know the same ones who left the
triforce behind for the races of
humanity to kill each other over but if
termina is
you know not hyrule did it have a
different creator or creators
my answer here may just blow your mind
you ready here it goes
it doesn't matter termina is an
alternate universe correct
kind of like low rule from a link
between worlds right personally i don't
question who created low rule either
laurel obviously has its own triforce
and therefore probably either its own
set of golden
goddesses or it was simply created along
with the creation of hyrule
as in this event created hyrule and all
other alternate universes as well
for all we know this is also true for
termina who says that just because the
triforce isn't visibly seen in the game
that means it doesn't exist
it is possible for a game to not revolve
around the golden triangles after all or
for all we know the four giants created
the land of termina since granny
directly implies that they created the
four
worlds the point is there are many
possibilities for the creation of this
alternate world here
which means it's closer to being
possible than impossible
so there you have it concise proof that
termina is real and link really did
travel there somehow and accomplish
great things by resetting time over and
over again
except for termina actually isn't real
and all exists inside of link's head
yeah now i'm going to prove that termina
is absolutely 100
not real to be honest it's actually
easier to prove that termina
isn't real than the opposite and no i'm
not implying that link was dead for the
entire game
come on guys if you're still believing
that nonsense
you need to do some more research maybe
start here with my theory on what
happened to the hero of time which is
this link by the way
link will be in the description and on
the screen but anyway in the first place
the portal makes no sense it's surreal
and feels
much more like an out of body acid trip
or dream than it does an
actual trip between worlds it's easily
explainable by saying link fell off his
horse in the woods and hit his head or
something and passed out and this was
the dream world that occurred the before
mentioned proof about link carrying gear
out of tourman at the end of the game
and skull kid's drawing on a tree stump
could also be disproven by simply saying
link didn't come out of his sleep state
yet and this was all
still a part of the dream as evidenced
by the woods seemingly being endless
and although this is admittedly a
completely speculative statement
it can't be proven wrong in addition to
the portal determiner making no
sense being inexplicably inside a tree
just how did ipona get to termina did
she fall
and land on a flower pod like link and
why is it that skull kid says he got rid
of epona yet we're just
supposed to believe epona magically
showed up at the romani ranch later in
the game did the skull kid randomly grow
a heart and leave
opponent in the safety and care of the
ranchers even though he's actively
trying to steal from link in the happy
masked salesman and you know destroy the
entire world and speaking of romani
every character that appears in game as
a parallel to their hyrulean
counterparts could be
again a result of link's own mind since
he's seen all of these people before and
it even makes sense since they're each
the same yet take on slightly different
roles which normally happens
in dreams besides the mayor of the city
of course who is
actually a brand new character but uh
who knows maybe this guy is link's lucid
dream nightmare monster he definitely
looks a lot like mine
uh anyway the skull kid's apparently
long friendship with the four giants
also makes very little sense
since this skull kid is theorized and
almost confirmed to be the same skull
kid that link met in ocarina of time in
the hyrulian lost woods
yet in majora's mask the skull kid has
apparently been friends with the four
giants
since before they created the four
worlds of termina unless this skull kid
is
actually ancient and has been hopping
back and forth between termina and
hyrule for some time now
this one also doesn't make too much
sense and is again easily explained by
saying the land of termina exists
only within link's own mind there is
also the official explanation from the
hyrule encyclopedia that explains
termina away as simply a fabrication
from the power of majora's mask
that only ever existed when you played
the game
but that makes even less sense than
anything else so far
plus the canon ocity of the dark horse
books is widely debated among fans
by far the easiest explanation for all
of this
messy majora madness would be that link
was riding in the woods
bonked his head had the dream of termina
then woke up later and just continued on
with his life
and before you say that an entire game
being just a dream is
lame just remember it's been done before
and with a fantastic story and reception
from players as well
and those are my two theories on why
termina is
absolutely real and why termina is
absolutely
not real which one do you believe let me
know in the comments and remember
this will influence the lore of this
channel i suppose so throw your opinion
out there hey guys thank you so much for
watching
as always ginormous thanks to my
supporters of which i have several new
faces to proudly announce
say hello to proelia kintarix challen
deal
glacio morgy t and
avvotoko gogol
thank you guys so much i hope you enjoy
your benefits and to those of you
watching if you're interested in getting
your name up here at the end of all of
my videos and having me butcher the
pronunciation of your name
publicly for thousands to hear click
that join button right under this video
or follow the links in the description
below
also down there are my fabulous social
media pages so come follow me for random
whims and thoughts on twitter that's all
for this one so i hope you have a great
rest of your day
this is massington abandon signing out
[Music]
you